i'm talina copian co-founder of purse
rehab we are a designer handbag and
leather goods restoration company today
i'm going to walk you through how my
team restores a burnt louis vuitton
never full bag this is the damier bean
never full print it's their top selling
bag today this bag is about two thousand
dollars depending on the size
unfortunately the bag was left by
accident on a burning electric stovetop
so the entire base is basically burnt
along with the piping and the side of
the bag is also burnt
to start we're going to unstitch the
base and in order to do that we're using
a round awl to remove the stitching and
remove the piping as well
we're going to clean off some of the
debris here using a soft bristle brush
this is a coated canvas bag basically
coated canvas is cotton that's coated
with polyvinyl chloride so that's why
you have that black color and the
hardness of the canvas
now we are drawing the template using
the base that we removed
and we are using cowhide leather this is
premium leather that matches the
existing trim on the bag
we're going to also skive the base at
the edges skiving is essentially shaving
down the leather and it's usually done
at the edges so that they're easily
foldable or stitchable
to match the interior red canvas of the
bag we are cutting a new piece of red
material to glue on and stitch onto the
base so that the interior is fully
compatible with the existing lining and
it's very much like the louis vuitton
material
we have to make a new piping to add to
the base this is made out of the same
leather
and so we cut out the piping and glue it
onto the base
and in addition to gluing it we will
also be stitching the piping so that
it's double reinforcement simply gluing
it isn't going to give it that extra
strength that it needs because it is a
basil it's a stress point on the back
in addition to making the base we are
going to recreate the burnt piece that's
on the side of the bag we are using
recycled louis vuitton material that's
in the damier bean print so that it
looks more seamless and it blends in
nicely with the bag
we try to align the pattern on the bag
first visually to make sure that we can
make it fit
once we cut it we are going to glue it
onto the
canvas and also stitch it
and once the recycled piece is on the
bag we're going to trim off the excess
burnt portion that's underneath the bag
once we've completed the preparation of
the new base it's time to put it on the
bag first we glue it onto the bag using
leather glue and then we are stapling
the base onto the body of the bag it's a
unique feature that our craftsmen use
here so that when we're stitching it
together it's solid and it doesn't move
once we're done stitching the base onto
the bag we are removing the staples
using a round tipped staple remover
which does not damage the canvas or the
leather
once we're done with the structural
issues and the repairs on the back we're
cleaning it using a mild cleaner to
revitalize and condition the canvas
it would have been impossible for us to
match the exact same pattern and
material we did our best to come up with
a solution that does blend well with the
bag and makes it usable in the long run
and that essentially was our client's
goal
you